this is the moment six years ago that
marked the start of a descent into hell
for this woman nazanin zagari radcliffe
here she is in tehran airport with her
one-year-old daughter who had just met
her parents for the first time stopped
then arrested then charged with spying
after so many full storms her family
hoped this week could finally see her
release they were a little bit cautious
as a family but certainly it's a big
step you know she couldn't have come
home without her passport before and
it's quite symbolic that the iranians
recognizing her
her coming home to britain
from the moment of arrest nazanin's
husband richard radcliffe campaigned for
her release outside the iranian embassy
on the steps of downing street even on
hunger strike it took its toll on him
too
his efforts impeded by then foreign
secretary boris johnson who in 2017
wrongly told parliament nazanin was in
iran to train journalists which would
have been a crime
this weekend the iranian authorities
finally returned her british passport
securing nazanin's release means
unpalatable choices according to those
involved such as a payment of 400
million pounds to iran despite all
they've done in recent years to
destabilize nearby countries
and boris johnson is about to cozy up to
saudi arabia even though they've just
executed 81 people global turmoil
reshaping global diplomacy the prime
minister unapologetic about the
alliances which he's forging we need to
make sure that we build the strongest
widest possible
coalition
to ensure that vladimir putin does not
succeed that we wean ourselves off
russian hydrocarbons and that's what the
uk is is helping to do but a coalition
with other unpleasant regimes prime
minister
well those are your words uh sam what we
want to do is build the white house that
iran and saudi arabia are not important
we want to build the widest possible
coalition
it seems a key part of the release
agreement is britain agreeing to pay
iran a 400 million pound debt dating
back to the 1970s there is progress
being made in the vienna based nuclear
negotiations and there's probably been a
sequence agreed to
release the dual nationals repay the
debt um and washington has um provided
whatever legal approvals are needed
from their end as well because tehran is
heavily sanctioned from washington
all they want is the other chair filled
around this table
could it come this week sam coates sky
news